[Música]
bem boa noite obrigado pelo convite
a pan american school e também o meu
irmão do ator marco aurélio telec
obrigado pelo convite
vamos abordar alguns aspectos evolutivos
da comunicação humana e vamos começar
descendo árvore até chegar aos dias de
hoje como estamos nos comunicando
pois bem na árvore qualificou como
primatas
a maior parte do tempo em no sentido da
existência de todos os símios por
alterações climáticas e por conseqüência
alimentares um macaquinho precisou
descer da árvore porque embaixo começou
a ter mais comida e com isso a evolução
teve que apurar as orelhas e os passos
porque ou nos diferenciar íamos para
animais velozes lutadores com predadores
com garras mais afiadas e não essas
unhas frágeis e dentes mais pontiagudos
para poder fazer frente aos que já
habitavam o solo mais tempo
então ou a diferenciação se daria por
esse lado ou desenvolvendo um pouco mais
tela encéfalo e algumas habilidades
dentre essas habilidades a comunicação e
foi o que aconteceu então com a abp
gestação ou seja com o andar nas duas
patilhas apenas liberou as os membros
superiores e essa habilidade e ajudou a
a que o cérebro desenvolver-se situações
mais delicadas e o adelgaçar aumento
progressivo da laringe também
proporcionou que as formações fosse
ficando mais elaboradas
lá em cima da árvore só clube unidos e
aspectos faciais gestuais ameaça defesa
lá embaixo para poder desenvolver
algumas técnicas de caçada se supõe que
foram os primeiros indicadores de que a
comunicação precisa ter mais vocábulos
para que esses vocábulos pudessem fazer
o combinado prévio de uma estratégia
mais eficaz para ser mais caça
dor do que caça uma das formas de ver se
o bicho é predador ou não é a posição
dos olhos no na cabeça quanto mais os
olhos são frontais mas ele é caçado do
que é capaz de algumas aves têm os olhos
bem lateralizados porque eles são
caçados quase todos os animais e caça
são só pequenos insetos e e grãos ou
seja com estou dizendo que o mano é um
predador por excelência
ele come quase tudo que é vivo não se
alimenta de quase tudo
eu brinco que inclusive cogumelos que já
me perguntaram se se todos os cogumelos
são comestíveis diz que sim todos são a
alguns são comestíveis uma vez só mas dá
pra comer todo sem problema
bom no descer da árvore uma das 1 dos
efeitos colaterais disso é que alguns
tempos evolutivos
eles têm que sofreu uma adaptação que
nem sempre a adaptação que o corpo
precisaria é proporcional ao que o clima
ea necessidade de sobrevivência vai
fornecendo por exemplo o nosso tempo de
gestação é um tempo prematuro
o bebê nasce com nove meses mas ele fica
mais 10 no marsúpio que também atende
pelo nome de colo materno porque porque
prematuro porque a maioria dos outros
bichos nasce com alguma condição de
sobrevivência pode não ser muito mas tem
alguma condição sobrevivência
o bichinho humano nasce com 0% de chance
de sobrevivência não tiver amanhã ele
todo o tempo e uma das possibilidades de
que esse de que esse nascimento se de de
um jeito prematuro também é ab prestação
enquanto de 4 a barriga pesava para
baixo a obstar a barriga começa o o
outro com o feto dentro começa a crescer
de uma maneira tal que acaba nascendo
antes do tempo e não essa complementação
é no colo
como é que se processa a comunicação a
partir desse ponto
quando nasci o bebezinho e aí nós temos
até perto dos dois anos o processo
primário de pensamento que é regido com
poucas poucas funções de formação de
entendimento e mais o imaginário então
ao nascer ele perde o a passar daqui é
tudo que eu quero hora que eu quero do
jeito que eu quero isso acontece no
outro mas ele ganha uma escrava
adivinhadora de pensamento e essa é a
primeira forma que a gente tende de
entender a comunicação com o resto do
mundo através de uma mãe que é tão
maravilhosa que adivinha se o bebê tashi
x está com fome e vai lá e atende não
precisa fazer mais nada lá que às vezes
ela chega antes até do choro e por um
bom tempo a regra da comunicação é esta
eu penso ela adivinha e me atende
ainda tá bem lá pelas tantas o bebezinho
já se comunica de alguma maneira pode
ser uma maneira incipiente mas já é
alguma comunicação teve que ver o copo
d'água e a dar bons se diz é assim já
ganha agora se só apontar o dedo é pouco
porque a mãe boa tem que forçar que ele
diga pelo menos vaga porque senão ela
vai continuar desviando o pensamento eo
reizinho vai se criar para todo sempre a
60 você sabe o resultado disso
então ele pensa água a mãe não adivinha
a tela de roma vai dizer que não
adivinhou e ele vai ter que dizer água
então ele pensa de novo e ela não
adivinhou
aí ele começa a incomodar ele pega uma
coisa no tapete faz barulho técnica
número um para quieto técnica dois pára
quieto de novo não só para tentar
entender por que atender e entender tem
a mesma raiz semântica como saber e
sabor também tem de passar por ele
o sabor de aprender então quando ela se
dê conta ela tem que traduzir o que ele
está querendo dizer ela vai entender que
ele queria água a ela vai ter que mexer
na regra preexistente então a regra eu
penso do adivinha agora diz assim
terminou isso agora tu pede eu alcanço
que história é essa
a regra não era essa nossa senhora a
regra eu penso adivinha
mas como ele é o menorzinho ele vai ter
que submeter a tal da regra nova
mas ele inaugura talvez nesse dia um
caderninho de rancores e talvez diga sim
vai ver que eu sou adotado o mesmo que
só me passa uma perna que o que vai
acontecer de novo isso então a regra
agora eu peço e tu vai lá e me busca mas
ele já está caminhando bonitinho e seta
já já dá conta de ir sozinho pegar lá o
seu guru de coisa parecida e ele estava
sem mãe busca-la yuri tipo beleza aqui o
que a mãe vai dizer meu filho a mãe já
foi nesse mercado já comprou vai ali e
pega o urt
ele vai pro caderninho denúncia não
mudaram a regra outra vez agora é eu
tenho que pedir a ele pede ela vai lá
enfim atende ou seja todo o processo
educacional precisa de readequações da
comunicação de tempo em tempo
é o jeito que a gente conversa com uma
criança no meu jeito que se conversa um
adulto
o jeito de uma conversa social não é o
mesmo jeito de uma conversa íntima a
conversa social não tem confronto a
gente escuta uma barbaridade na na
conversa social e faz uma cara de
paisagem
agora uma pessoa íntima nos diz aquela
barbaridade agentes cabelo não é
possível acho que eu vou acreditar nisso
a apresentação não tive tempo de fazer
tal coisa no mundo social
ok agora se alguém disser que não teve
tempo de fazer tal coisa que nós
combinamos
eu vou ser obrigado não foi prioridade
tem todo o jeito de não ter feito que
não era uma prioridade mas dizem que não
têm tempo é uma desculpa que não o aluno
que vai dizer é eu saí mal mãe mas todos
saíram mal não se todos tirar uma nota
baixíssima não tem que falar com a
professora porque eram 40 alunos é os 40
tiraram nota dois ou três que tirar uma
nota 2 não é o problema o problema é
dizer que todo mundo tirou nota 2
porque deve ter tido uns 10 ou 20 que
tiraram nota boa então são crimes
diferentes não pode ser uma dessas
atenção não estudou o suficiente mas o
outro crime mais grave porque eu tô eu
tô prostituir
a comunicação e às vezes por por falta
de confronto a pessoa vai subindo os
degraus vinhos da comunicabilidade
humana achando que o que está agradando
que está funcionando aquilo não foi só
por uma educação entre aspas que aquilo
foi se deixando passar nesse sentido
nenhuma palavra vem isenta do do signo
do significado é por exemplo e ainda na
semântica é ensinar significa colocar um
signo dentro de educar significa
caminhar lado a lado no processo da
aquisição da linguagem os humanos são
muito parecidos em praticamente todas as
línguas com linguiça chamado jacobson
pesquisou mil e 67 línguas para compra
concluir que nessas 1.067 que ele
concluiu o estudo mama femama e mamãe
eram muitos e muitos semelhantes tinham
um emmy eo a oa tem uma explicação muito
fácil porque a vogal sonora mais aberta
mais fácil é o que a gente vai gritar
quando doeu alguma coisa a gritar o i né
não vai gritar
a outra está a ae
mas o m qual seria a explicação que o m
explica mamãe em tantas línguas e não
coincidentemente é porque o ato de mamar
verbo na a mama glândula e mamãe a que
proporcionam essa é essa conjunção
explicação também o ovo de colombo como
é que a gente faz com a boca pra mamar é
um m para dentro quando está com fome
aquela divulgadora de pensamento está
fazendo sei lá o quê que não está
atendendo beleza esse m para dentro eo a
numa uma então não preciso ensinar que
mamãe são a mesma coisa o que tem que
ensinar é o pd pai aquele lá atrás é o
teu pai o que serve mesmo o pai dele
ajuda um pouco a e o mp já tem outras
singularidades que se nós tivéssemos
mais tempo a gente ia avançar muito
mas o mote seria esse é um teste um
desenho um desenho com muitas curvas
dizem mimoso bem jeitoso e outro desenho
cheio de pontas e eu dissesse para vocês
um decide um desses desenhos foi
batizado de malu uma e outro desenho foi
batizado de targets 101 por cento das
pessoas acertam que malu uma seria o
desenho arredondado e o paquete seria o
desenho pontiagudo porque a boca dizendo
malu mahé cheio de curvas marketing ip
paineís m mãe etc
bom então da árvore em diante para baixo
desenvolve uma uma palavra falada que é
maravilhosa e 77 até chegar nem vou
fazer um salto pulando a partir da data
do gutenberg com a nec com a palavra
escrita podendo ser impressa isso
popularizou muito conhecimento mas vamos
pular por agora as redes sociais na a
tecnologia proporcionou o que seria o
clímax da da comunicação e da
comunicabilidade do que o que conversar
é usar a palavra pra acertar coisas
ninguém é louco pensar que a gente vai
conversar pra brigar atua enfim nós qual
o fenômeno tende mais enxerga hoje que
as pessoas cada vez mais estão ouvindo
apenas a própria voz
o que dá de discussão no via torpedo via
anos comércio computador que a pessoa
não leu o que o outro serviu não leu e
ela segue discutindo sozinho segue
brigando pra terminar pra estragar o
namoro o torpedo é maravilhoso quem
quiser estragar o namoro
o torcedor é fantástico porque cada um
naquela ansiedade de responder não
entendeu o que o outro disse porque não
tem tom de voz também tá sic está
telegráfico então pra como uma linguagem
da sedução no bom sentido é o torpedo
bem vindo mas pra acertar coisas que
precisam ser acertadas péssima idéia
muito ruim
é nesse sentido de uma uma polarização
aonde também ninguém está a fim de
trocar idéias a pessoa quer
com sua própria ideia e tentar convencer
o outro como se o o grande axioma dos
nossos dias fosse não tem porém nem
senão quem concorda comigo tem razão
porque não concordar comigo não serve
não funciona essa a brincadeira que eu
proponho que se a comunicação evoluiu a
esse ponto que nós podemos nos ver
qualquer pessoa em qualquer canto do
mundo
é isso seria maravilhoso se pudéssemos
na mesma proporção
manter uma atenção ao que o outro está
dizendo essa revolução seria maravilhosa
porém uma certa ansiedade uma certa
pressa em opinar até sobre coisas que a
gente não tá podendo opinar porque não
entendeu o recado do outro mas como todo
mundo está dando uma opinião a pessoa às
vezes sente compelida opinião ela nem às
vezes nem sabe sobre o que está falando
mas já já opinou já discordou
um amigo meu professor conta que ele
dando umas aulas de de cênica que ele
estava usando o xerox de um texto
baseado em cena ou seja nem era o
original e sempre vão ter alguns alunos
vencer mas eu não concordo com cênica é
é até poder não concordar com o tal do
cênica teria que ter conhecido um meio
que pra valer a obra dele para poder
realmente dá a tal da opinião
então pra finalizar o efeito colateral
dessa comunicação tão instantânea é tem
produzido e proporcionado muita resposta
de reflexo e não de reflexão e falar só
por espontaneidade sem ter transformado
aquela proteína e aminoácidos para poder
então havia uma digestão é meio uma
situação só que à tarde é uma situação
que não teria um real acréscimo para que
a gente aprenda a a entender o outro e
nesse sentido atender o outro e aí sim
poder viver melhor em família e com os
amigos e namorados
muito obrigado pela atenção até uma
próxima oportunidade
[Aplausos]